in 2016 we held 50.6% of the credit card
market share and 70 point three percent
of the debit card market share today
they have one point four six billion
visa cards in circulation generating
over four point three million dollars in
sales in over 160 countries every single
year but how do we say even get into
this business and grow to become the
market leader stick around till the end
to find out
[Music]
welcome to hari sadhus so it all started
with Bank of America which launched a
consumer credit card with the maximum
credit limit of three hundred dollars
this credit card was aimed at middle
class people and small merchants and as
a result Bank of America started a
BankAmericard program in 1958 at First
Bank of America's plan was to keep this
program exclusive to state of California
but starting in 1965 Bank of America
started licensing BankAmericard to
several other banks outside of
California in the late 1960s dee hog the
leader of a group of licensee banks
changed the creation of an association
she suggested that this association
should be a joint venture so that each
member could take advantage of
socialized payments while also having an
even playing field soon enough in 1970
DeHoff became the first president of the
National Bank America card ink or NV I
this was right after Bank of America
past control of BankAmericard to issue
banks who comprised the National Bank of
MetroCard incorporation NPI became an
independent non stock company who
managed promoted and developed
BankAmericard systems in the United
States while Bank of America gives you
the control of BankAmericard over 2 mb i
eating cut all ties with bank america
Garden Bank of America still had the
power to issue international licenses
and that's exactly what they did in 1972
they greater 15 countries international
licenses in 1974 a multinational
corporation was established called a
Banco this corporation managed a global
bank America card program
in 1976 the directors of a bank of
United there's several international
networks into one single global network
however there was one issue many
countries were hesitant in an issuing
Bank of America cards even though there
was very small ties with the bank to
eliminate this issue detox adjusted name
in a company visa would you recognize
and accept it around the world visa debt
for reasoning International Service
Association and what's cool about the
name is that it's pronounced the same
way in every single language and this
marks the formal birth of visa meanwhile
the first Bank of America card debit
card was introduced in 1975 they were
actually pretty late to the party
considering that debit cards had been
around since 1966 Lisa also joined the +
ATM network in 1986 this lot consumers
to always access their cash 24 hours a
day easily around the world in 1986
this also develops multiple currency
clearing and settlements with 21
currencies this was a big change for
travel people could not follow from
country to country and use her debit
card or credit card in each of these
countries people no longer had to deal
with exchanging currencies however they
did have to deal with
Risa's hefty fees nonetheless these
fever are preferred over all the hassle
required the other method by the late
1980s we had grown this huge corporation
they sponsor the first Olympic Games in
1988 in Seoul South Korea
in 1989 they significantly increased
security by implementing electronic
signature capabilities this was made
possible by our acquisition of
interlinks they further weave in
security in 1993 by being first apply
neutral network technologies appearance
this heavily reduced fraud at this point
they were internationally established as
a credit card and debit card issuer was
great security implementation as a
result it was time for them to go
mainstream in 1995 Visa introduced a
Visa Check Card which is basically the
equivalent of bardia check both greater
security
in the same year they also helped
co-create EMV which is a chip card
specification EMV ensures
interoperability between all chip
enabled cards and terminals in 1996
Lisa's first international financial
literacy program launches today this
program is offered in over 20 countries
and helps millions of people every
single year manage the money then soon
enough 1997 rolled around which is a
huge year for visa this year
Lisa's total payment volume reaches 1
trillion dollars in just a single year
and then in cousin one Lisa reaches a
total of 1 billion issued cards this
year he also lost a zero liability
program which protects card holders from
liability of fraudulent charges and then
in 2004 there are total debit volume
surpasses their talk credit volume they
also introduced advanced authorization
which analyzes in signs of each piece of
transaction a risk score in real-time at
this point visa was really a global
conglomeration but they were still
separated however this wouldn't last for
much longer on October 11 2006 these had
announced a merging of their businesses
Refik Canada Visa International and visa
USA were joined to create Visa Inc visa
Europe would become a separate company
owned by the issuer banks and the issue
of banks would also have a minority
stake in Visa Inc this process went
pretty smoothly and by the end of 2007
the corporate restructuring was all over
and at this point visa was ready to go
public on March 18 to 2018 Visa went
public with half of their shares they
sold 406 million shares at $44 of share
and this is to lows over the expected
price range of 37 to 42 dollars so
clearly Mesa was off to a great start
they actually ended up raising seventeen
point nine billion dollars which is the
largest initial public offering in US
history the stock has consistently
increased over the past decade and now a
single share cost over 160 dollars now
that's all re a tremendous increase but
when you consider they are in a
a four-to-one split that increase
becomes exponentially bigger they have
gone to almost 10 times their initial
public offering but despite all this
vast success they never became a coffee
company there were always an ever
dabbling company in 2008 it launched a
visa mobile payments platform look
through the accelerated mobile payments
in 2014 the interest visa checkout which
is a much more easy and secure way to
pay for stuff online and finally in 2016
Visa Inc and meeting Europe reunited as
one global company they are very excited
about the future and think that mobile
payments will take over as a primary way
to pay by 2020 and thatís how the visas
that we know today was created in the
end visa is a global payments technology
company that enables consumers
businesses banks and governments to pay
each other using digital transactions we
said truly has revolutionized payments
or at last 50 years and continue to do
so by strongly supporting technology
it's just Apple pay and Google Play
there are fortune 500 company and
bringing billions of dollars revenue
every single year which all makes sense
make considered significant role they
play in many of our day-to-day lives but
that's not hard for you guys on the visa
they should comment down below what
company you would like me to cover next
also if you guys like this we get a
venture up a life and consider
subscribing for more
like this one buckle then I'm Mari I'll
see you guys
you